in our series welcome school matters
we're looking at how a major reform that
could affect millions of high school
students in the aftermath of the college
admissions scandal so only on CBS this
morning that's another only on CBS this
morning I like it we do that
the College Board is announcing a plan
to consider socioeconomic factors and
admissions to make sure that every
student has a fair shot sounds like a
good idea right the board's landscape
program will give colleges consistent
information on each applicants high
school and neighborhood the idea here is
to highlight resourceful students who
have done more with less the board is
also increasing security measures to
curb cheating on the SAT meg Oliver
looked into the impact of these changes
and she joins us in the studio meg what
you find good morning Gail as more
colleges and universities become test
optional over criticism of tests
favoring the wealthy the College Board
is giving colleges a reason to continue
using the SAT as part of the admissions
process it's solution landscape a way it
says evens the playing field for all
students how many colleges are you
applying to I'm applying to ten colleges
which is what my guidance counselor
recommended that's a lot yeah why so
many I think you want to cast a wide net
Simone Kyle is quick to admit applying
to college is stressful over the weekend
she took her second stab at the SATs
hoping to boost her score what's it like
taking the SATs it's nerve-racking
because you feel like every question
that you answer you're thinking about
like will I get into college
Simone attends a selective college prep
high school in New York City maintains a
3.8 grade point average play sports and
volunteers but she doesn't know if it's
enough to get into the school that she
wants how hard is it to trust the
process after the cheating scandal it
can be concerning because you're putting
so much trust into this process you're
meeting all the guidelines and you're
meeting all the deadlines and all the
things that you have to do and you're
trusting that other side to consider
everyone fairly and not be bribed is the
tea system fair for everyone I think
it's fair and I think that it's fair but
it has limits David Coleman is CEO of
the College Board in wake of the college
admissions scandal he's announcing
changes to prevent future violations
like where tests need to be taken we're
not going to allow those environments
outside of schools anymore and if we
ever do will have multiple checks on the
identity above the student and Proctor
so back in May on CBS this morning you
announced the adversity score it's not
an individual score for that student it
really is about the broad context they
grew up in you're changing that to
landscape why we made changes because we
heard and thought we could do better
they're no longer as a single number
that tries to sum up your neighborhood
in school today we'll share with
everyone exactly I would calculate it
and within a year for every student and
family they'll be able to see the
information for their neighborhood in
school landscape looks at how the
applicants test score compares with
other students in their high school and
evaluates factors including local
college attendance rates median family
income and crime numbers if you need a
caveat like landscape how fair is
standardized testing to begin with what
it is is a fair measure of achievement
but what it doesn't tell you is the
context in which that achievement
occurred it might be useful to know wow
they achieved that score on the SAT but
it was 300 points higher than anyone
ever at that school
that's an amazing context I would say
it's a start
what I say it's enough college counselor
Gilbert Vivaro says the changes can only
do so much I'm hoping you know it's not
exploited I'm hoping that it's you know
useful what it's made to be it won't be
until we see some major shifts and
admissions rates among students of color
low-income first-generation can we say
that okay
progress is being made it's it'll have
to be a wait-and-see at this point some
critics might worry that overeager
parents will move into lower-income
neighborhoods to give their kids an
advantage in the application process but
the College Board says you can't be
admitted or denied based on landscape
it's only a consideration
any system can be gamed though that's
the worry people do that now just to get
their kids to look at school I thought
it was really interesting that when they
announced the project they weren't gonna
tell students or families what that
adversity score was but now they're
gonna be transparent sharing that
information they think it's really
important and within a year you will
have the information about the
neighborhood schools and then the high
school and they really are hoping that
this will help rural schools you know
maybe somewhere in the middle of the
country where the universities are not
that you know aware of certainly seems
like a good start it is a good start
until you can address the landscape out
in the real world I mean this is an
adjustment thank you very much